et nabila et thomas leur nouvelle nounou
vient de sortir de prison est ce une
rumeur ou pas une rumeur je rappelle que
vous avez peut-être dubaï et qu'elle ait
eu un enfant qui s'appelle je sais plus
comment l'allalin millan à sa garçons ah
oui j'suis pas mille franchement tepa la
page 1 h que les bayonnais bien alors
c'est une info rumeur du parfumeur
c'est faux non c'est vrai c'est pas vrai
alors à tourner l'info ça vous dérange
pas la fin est sorti donc dans public
magazine donc le magazine de myriam pas
d'en bas qui dit donc la chose suivante
que effectivement il aurait engagé un
homme en l'occurrence un homme nous nous
que nabil aurait rencontré en prison et
qui vit prison je veux dire la photo
année par l'anc le monsieur existe il
tient le bébé dans ses bras il s'appelle
en trader nous et on écoute cobelguard
une du corps nounou qui les aide
ponctuellement et ce monsieur quand même
kamel guennoun un art c'est l'acteur qui
a eu un petit rôle
le rôle de mahmoud en nicky larson et
qui au mois d'avril a été juste et
ajuster ajuste écopé de dix mois de
prison dont cinq ferme pour violences
sur son sur sa compagne
je vais éviter de décrire la scène parce
qu'elle a été quand même hyper violent
avait décrit dans closer à l'époque
c'est un récidiviste puisqu'il avait
c'est pour ça qu'il a pris 2,5 mois
ferme
je suis désolé qu'ils ont quand même
reçu des visites pas mon enfant que ce
monsieur porte en photos du magazine est
récidiviste pour rire de violences
conjugales un nouveau jour là une chose
la mère de ses enfants qui l'a fait deux
fois de la prison pour violences
conjugales la prison mais il a pris cinq
mois faire parce qu'il était juste parce
qu'ils étaient récidivistes violences
conjugales sur la vision que mal aurait
engagé bank comme redire homme à tout
faire rouge pas quoi faire du corps
alors oui je regarde ce que tu pourrais
très bien à bil'in qui a hébergé c'est
une amie c'est un c'est un record
ponctuel sur paris c'est absolument pas
une nounou
je veux dire nabila n'a pas de nounou
d'ailleurs elle garde son enfant avec sa
mère qui quitte avec eux et qui s'occupe
du petit ils ont aucune nounou ensuite
excusé moi ça voudrait dire que chaque
personne qui a fait de la prison ne peut
plus travailler ça n'a plus droit
travailler sinon il se retrouve à la une
de public non et
condamné petit le mans mais je rencontre
une ambulance aux urgences et compte dix
ans de prison deux genres travailler six
avis important mascouche et à leurs
papiers y avait aucun aucunement alors
c'est juste que voilà je suis désolé
alors tu dis que c'est pas une nounou
mais bon là le photographe qui l'a suivi
bas il était là quand même pendant un
certain bout de temps et c'était lui qui
gardaient le petit donc voilà après
c'est pas je dis pas évidemment qu'on a
le droit à une réinsertion évidemment
qu'on a droit plein de choses et et la
prison est fait pour ça mais quand même
je sais pas alors forcément mario balti
de confier son enfant a nié aujourd'hui
en 3d qui s'attache à donner la parole
aux autres parce que la question qu'on
peut se poser c'est est-ce que c'est
bien effectivement d'eau de de réinsérer
quelqu'un qu'elle soit une prison si on
avait un serpent après il retourne la
délinquance personne doit les faire
travailler
mais ce qu'aiment tant nabila keita qui
est un exemple parce que c'est bien de
faire va de prendre on va dire en
exemple quelqu'un qui par deux fois a
été jugée non pas pour vol de voiture ou
veulent étalage m'enfin violences
conjugales oui sébastien mais déjà il ya
une première question qui se pose
pourquoi nabila un garde du corps parce
que déjà ça c'est aberrant moi qui suis
des stars toute la journée
il ya quasiment pas une seule star
française qui se balade avec un mail à
une autre question pourquoi nabila qu'il
faudrait de ces journées et nous
[Applaudissements]
j'ai la divination à temps et dans le
monde entier je peux même te dire que
tom cruise se balade sans garde du corps
will smith aussi toutes les stars
françaises se balade sans garde du corps
c'est très très rare de voir des gens se
balader avec des gardes du corps alors
une starlette de télé-réalité ok alors
les parler de télé réalité aujourd'hui
c'est comme un peu et nouveaux
footballeurs ils sont menacés sont en
brio les foudres de télé
[Applaudissements]
mais pas marché c'est tout ça comme
excuse moi des gens n'importe quoi mais
c'est pas une médaille talaudière et
jean terminée mais là peut se balader
n'avait aucun argument tinarrage et au
canada guy lagache lui plaît pas du tout
aux magali il suit toutes les stars
depuis maintenant je demande entière
creuser h m en fous elle si elle un
problème en 30 sec juste comparer
apprécié c'est la muse de claquer son
cousin deux un garde du corps de son
problème c'est en tout cas mieux pour
laisser casser par les autres juste la
différence entre tom cruise et nabila
c'est que tom cruise
il sait qu'il est une star et nabila
elle pense qu'à l'einstein
vanille attendez attendez accordé à
cordes et s'il vous plaît s'il vous
plaît vraiment c'est sur le sujet le
plus futile que tout le monde prend la
parole
attestant c'était surtout est ce que oui
ou non vous êtes choqués est ce que
c'est en tant qu'exemple ou pas quelle
réinsère quelqu'un qui unit deux fois a
été jeune a été accusé de violence
conjugale encore une fois c'est pas vol
de bagnoles c'est pas ces violences
conjugales c'est frappé par deux fois
vous avez carrément raison bien sûr il
faut que les gens se réinsère quand même
ce mec il a été condamné deux fois pour
le tabasser des femmes quand on voit le
le moscow stokes et moi j'aurai un peu
repris après un petit peu et non moi je
suis d'accord c'est choquant qu'elle
exhibe un mec qui a été pendant les 6 %
excuse moi c'est dans les magazines donc
pour moi ça fait mal mais bien exhibe sa
vie c'est choquant encore une fois vous
l'avez dit ce sera un bol de bagnols
volatiles on dirait bon le mec il a fait
une connerie ok c'est quand même
violences et des actes contre les femmes
en ce moment se bat contre les
féminicides oui c'est choquant les
oranje non je trouve que juste pour te
donner un petit peu mon avis c'est quand
même compliqué cette fille tu te dis à
laquelle donne un exemple moyens au
début puis après la poignarder son
copain qui rêvent que tu dis que
normalement elle essaye de faire des
choses qui s est un exemplaire pendant
quelques jours provoque un dicton
avignon mais elle montre qu'elle est
fidèle en amitié quelque part et qu'elle
s'en foutront pense et là dessus elle a
peut-être raison si c'est son ami et
apprécié à la bourriche sur lui à la
droite se dire je ne gèlent en bosses je
l'aide c'est mon âge dumas compresseur
de prison c'est quand même assez beau
alors qu'elle sait qu'elle est critiquée
quoi il s'agit les émeutes sociales
excusez moi tous les deux la star
cannabis pour moi c'est une star en
attendant on a tendance mais n'a pas la
même dimension
[Musique]
la peinture oui mais moi je chausse
attendez jamais jamais jamais ma bilour
un paparazzi derrière elle parce que ça
les apparitions publiques cette semaine
c'était chaud tient la personne et la
semaine dernière et parce que ça c'est
une star si tu te renvoyer la réponse
est oui voila je reconnais que ces
belles heures à bad tu est un vrai choix
de la ville au sort pas on a juste
besoin d'être une seconde score en une
de public qui s'adresse particules en
plus aux jeunes une habile et en une du
public avec thomas ça marche est bien
citoyen honnête ça fait vous avoir fait
ça marche pas forcément plus que
d'autres c'est un et ça marche ça va
j'ai dire oui mais je dis ça change la
donne tellement sur instagram week-end
dernier
vous savez la phrase de voulait de andy
warhol qui avait dit chaque personnalité
aura droit un jour à son quart d'heure
de célébrité mondiale est belle et dans
l à son droit elle a fait la cour de
paris match marine a comme ça fait un
peu débat de vue autour d'une table ce
qui m'intéresse c'est enfin j'ai fait
des petits calculs dans ma tête la
semaine dernière on avait mis la cave et
donc 2 millions de followers sur
instagram et qui nous avouer avoir gagné
50 mille euros par mois entre autres
vins de duras non entre 20 et 50 euros
magali on a eu ma galerie pardon de nana
le fil à ben ali en a un ça va c'est
vraiment je suis
je trouve le problème le prince et qui
barrent un peu
[Musique]
la ville a donc le double de followers
imaginez deux fois nabila gagne donc
entre 10 et 100 mille euros il sachant
que son mec gaga là on a admis c'est
vrai qu'à vivre le couple doit être à
150 mille euros par mois mais oui c'est
assez fascinant mais gagner de l'argent
c'est pas des dunes cear pardon chemin
des stars comme elle alors je suis pas
au fait tu confirmes c'est la tante elle
pourrait veiller pour 100 millions le
coût pourrait gagner plus de 100000
euros par mois entre ceux qui peuvent le
faire enfin et c'est une star les
influences euse mai mais ça c'est une
star à bruxelles bien nabila moi j'aime
bien c'est l'histoire un peu pamiers là